Ngày hai mít tư thường người các phép ai phá Lai Stain bao gồm ha mắt và phá ta đặt thật thận thành lập của cơ quan kỹ chỉ tạm thời,
đặc lập để quán lý dậy gà ra hậu xung đột theo tuyên bố chung sau hai ngày đem phán giói cập làm chung ra, tại cơ rộ,
huy bán mới sĩ báo của mất kinhên bật phi đảng phái của gà ra, chừng chính nghiệm điều hành công việc hàng ngày và cũng cất cơ xí cụu thiết yêu chung đi ra.
Các phép phái khẳng định, cơ quan này sẽ hoạt động trong khuyên khổ chất nhẹm dài chim cút ra, đồng thời kêu gọi thành lập một uống bán cút tế giám xác việc tài trợ,
có thực hiện các lỗ lực tài thiết toàn dịn dài ra. Các phê nhỏng bá Lai Stain yêu cầu từ gẹn đầy đủ thật nương bán,
kêu gọi giút quân hoàn toàn giữa mỏ lực báo vầy vụ được gịt mở tất cả các cơ khẩu,
cũng cấp vệ trợ như đạo phầu bị cà trợ. Các nhỏng, palai Stain, kêu gọi hồi đồng bóa li hợp hút,
ra hịt quết cho phép các lực lượng cút tế tạm thời được đề xuất sáng xác lệ yếu bán.
Còn đây, tuy nhiên palai Stain đã xerang vẫn sẽ là yêu tiền hàng đầu.
Các phép phái khám kết đủ thật của ra giậm giải hơn, để tuy nhiên các nổ lực chiến chiến.
Vương tế việc tài kích hoạt tổ chức xài phòng palai Stain để đại diện cho tạm thình với palai Stain.